en el último vídeo teníamos una
superficie en donde la altura la altura
z en realidad era una función que
dependía de xy de ye y nos dio una
superficie en el espacio tridimensional
ahora vamos a tratar de meter nuestras
cabezas alrededor de lo que es el
gradiente pero de una función que
depende de tres variables y realmente
pues es para mí muy difícil imaginar un
campo escalar verdad en tres dimensiones
porque no podemos graficar en la cuarta
dimensión no podemos imaginarlo así que
vamos a plantear un modelo de lo que no
sé de cómo se comporte la temperatura en
una habitación y que dependa de mi
posición de mi posición en ese cuarto
que es en la posición x y z verdad en
cada una de las direcciones así que no
sé digamos que tengo un
qué será déjenme pensar para esta para
esta temperatura que en el centro de la
habitación vamos a tener no se me puede
imaginar que a medida que avanzamos más
lejos del centro donde haya una fuente
de calor pues la función de temperatura
va a ser decreciente verdad y digamos
que en el centro el centro está en el
origen es decir el centro está en en x
igual a igual a 7 igual a 0 así que
vamos a plantear un modelo que diga no
sé si esto sea un buen modelo para para
la difusión de la temperatura pero
digamos que es 10 por el ala menos ere
cuadrada
y bueno ustedes dirán porque pongo r en
vez de x y z bueno yo sólo estoy
diciendo que decae la temperatura de
forma exponencial a medida que me voy
alejando de nuestra fuente de calor ok
de forma radial
vamos a ver cuál es la distancia la
distancia radial en realidad pues lo que
tenemos es que r cuadrada muy bien
nuestra variable r cuadrada es el radio
de la distancia o la distancia de mi
punto al centro es decir x r cuadrada es
x cuadrada más y cuadrada maceta
cuadrada que es el teorema de pitágoras
en tres dimensiones verdad así que vamos
a escribir nuestra función como que
depende exclusivamente de x y y ceta es
decir la temperatura que depende de x
jay-z es 10 x
a la menos y aki sustituimos re cuadrada
por equis cuadrada más y cuadrada maceta
cuadrada muy bien eso es lo que está
escrito arriba pero en las variables x
jay-z verdad entonces después de darle
una poca intuición a lo que estamos
proponiendo bueno no importa realmente
si el modelo es bueno no aquí vamos a
tratar de aprender cómo conceptualizar
al menos lo que es un campo escalar
verdad entonces todas las medidas de
este campo escalar es que en un punto
del cuarto del espacio tridimensional
nos vas o nos va a asociar un valor real
un número que es la temperatura y eso
tiene sentido verdad ahora si tuviéramos
que tomar un punto en esa habitación y
evaluamos la temperatura en ese punto
pues obtenemos un valor de temperatura
verdad entonces por eso se llama un
campo escalar a este tipo de funciones
ahora cómo se vería el gradiente de esta
función vamos a ver cómo se vería el
gradiente
el gradiente de esta función va a
decirnos en qué dirección y de hecho el
gradiente va a generar un campo
vectorial verdad porque nos dicen qué
dirección tenemos el más grande aumento
de temperatura como vimos en el vídeo
anterior de hecho la magnitud de los
vectores de este campo vectorial dado
por el gradiente nos dice en qué
dirección mirarlo es como como casi una
una pendiente tridimensional digamos es
pero eso no te haya confundido así que
vamos a calcular el gradiente y después
veremos un diagrama para ver esto de
forma más intuitiva así que vamos a
borrar esta cosa de aquí abajo muy bien
y vamos a cambiar del color azul porque
es un poco rey no sé nauseabundo así que
pongamos la orden de rosa así que el
gradiente de nuestra función te va a ser
igual a la parcial de t respecto de x
por el vector unitario en la dirección x
correcto más la derivada parcial de t
respecto de i
el vector en la dirección y el vector
unitario más la parcial de t la parcial
de t respecto de z por el vector
unitario en la dirección zeta la
dirección vertical muy bien ahora
simplemente enchufamos lo que dice
nuestra bar y nuestra función t en esta
expresión y el gradiente de t es la
parcial de t respecto de x o que tenga
una función de tres variables como
calculó esta derivada parcial bueno pues
hay que recordar que si tomamos la
derivada parcial respecto a x sólo
tomamos allí y así y acepta como si
fueran constantes así que hagamos eso
tomamos la derivada del interior de esta
función verdad entonces al derivar esto
respecto de x pues podemos primero
distribuir el menos este signo menos en
todas las variables entonces nos queda
menos x cuadrada menos y cuadrada menos
está cuadrada y ahora al derivar
respecto de x ye cuadrada y se está
cuadrada son constantes así que al
derivar respecto de x se hacen 0 verdad
entonces la derivada es
los 2 x que es la derivada de menos x
cuadrada verdad ahora falta multiplicar
por la derivada de la función exterior
verdad que es 10 por ea la menos esta
expresión de x jay-z
ahora la derivada de una exponencial
pues es ella misma verdad eso es lo
sorprendente de la función exponencial y
bueno luego multiplicamos por una
constante que es 10 ajá entonces
realmente la constante pues simplemente
sale de la derivada y finalmente nos
queda que la derivada de exteriores 10
por ea la menos x cuadrada más cuadrada
más zeta cuadrada muy bien y todo eso lo
multiplicamos por el vector unitario en
la dirección x verdad que lo ponemos
como y lo pongo en verde para no pues no
perdernos ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
para la dirección y así que ahora cuál
es la derivada parcial respecto de ella
de esta parte de arriba y bueno pues es
si es equivalente a cuando poníamos x
así que esto es
- 2
y la derivada de todo esto es nuevamente
10 por ea la menos x cuadrada malla
cuadrada maceta cuadrada y esto todo
esto lo multiplicamos ahora por el
vector unitario en la dirección y que es
el jota verdad
y finalmente la derivada parcial de la
temperatura respecto de z entonces es
exactamente lo mismo que en los casos
anteriores es menos 12 está por 10 x 10
x a la menos menos equis cuadrada
massieu cuadrada maceta cuadrada y eso
es simplemente usar la regla de la
cadena verdad tomando a las otras
variables como constantes
ahora esto lo multiplicamos por el
vector unitario en la dirección zeta que
lo ponemos como carl esto podemos
simplificarlo un poco verdad es todo por
ejemplo vamos a escribirlo aquí el
gradiente de t es menos 20 que es 2 por
10 por el ala menos x cuadrada más y
cuadrada maceta cuadrada y esto por el
vector i
- ah me falta multiplicar por equis
ahora ya lo puse ahora menos 20 por ok
creo que esto lo podemos simplificar de
otra forma pero de todos modos lo más
importante es que siempre me encuentro
con gradientes que son fáciles de
calcular yo ya me estaba pasando
la parte más difícil es la intuición así
que vamos a tratar de generar la
intuición de lo que realmente este
gradiente nos nos dice ok entonces si
queremos saber el gradiente en un punto
del espacio basta con sustituir el
gradiente de t en un punto particular xz
verdad entonces recordemos que t es la
temperatura en cualquier punto de un
campo escalar así que ahora cuando
tengamos el gradiente en cualquier punto
simplemente le asociamos un vector
porque tiene componentes y jk verdad
donde la magnitud en cada componente son
las derivadas parciales así que tenemos
hemos pasado de un campo escalar a un
campo vectorial y vamos a ver lo que
parece muy bien aquí recurrimos otra vez
a una
a una gráfica vamos a explorar un poco
cómo se ve esto creo que es bastante
bueno el dibujo verdad porque lo que
este campo vectorial nos está pintando
en realidad es el gradiente de la
función ok que acabamos de resolver para
para anteriormente y como podemos ver
cuando esta gráfica esté bueno el
programa que lo hizo recoge varios
puntos y dibuja los gradientes los los
dibuja como vectores así la longitud de
los vectores son las magnitudes de los
de las componentes en x jay-z y luego
los suma como como se suman los vectores
verdad entonces la dirección está dada
según las componentes y jk y como
podemos ver la inclusión es bastante
interesante a medida que más y más nos
acercamos a nuestra fuente de calor la
temperatura aumenta y aumenta y aumenta
verdad los vectores de medida se acercan
más vamos a hacerle un poco de su min
muy bien nos acercamos más
ok así está ahora estamos en este campo
vectorial y podemos ver que mientras más
y más nos acercamos a la fuente de calor
los vectores es decir la velocidad a la
que la temperatura aumenta se hace más y
más grande verdad de todos modos espero
que esto no te haya confundido cuando me
enteré de los gradientes creo que supe
que era algo muy sencillo pero la
intuición siempre es lo más interesante
y espero que esta analogía en cuanto a
temperaturas o bueno este modelo de la
temperatura haga más claro pensar en lo
que son los gradientes de todos modos
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo